roland tutrel bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors tout d'abord êtes
vous surpris par cette décision c'est
que nokia avait promis de préserver les
emplois au moins pendant deux ans nokia
avait promis de préserver le niveau
d'emploi et d'augmenter le nombre
d'emplois en r&d l'augmenter de 500 nets
de passer de 2000 à 2500 il se trouve
que ils ont toujours joué avec cet
engagement ils n'ont pas tenu
totalement on n'a jamais atteint les
2500 et on a appris récemment que dès
2018 il avait prévu de licencier et de
supprimer une grande partie de la r&d en
france donc tout en embauchant des
salariés nouveau des jeunes à lannion à
nausée en région parisienne il préparait
le plan de licenciement pour les
renvoyer à la fin des engagements qu'ils
avaient pris un coup et gouvernement
français le gouvernement français se
sent trahi les salariés encore pire
évidemment et on fragilise énormément la
r&d en france la recherche et
développement ses 40 % de la recherche
et développement française qui risque de
disparaître il cependant arrive à son
terme
alors le plan de licence non menace plus
de 1200 emplois 402 sur le site de
lannion sur 7 172 salariés c'est le
c'est plus de la moitié des effectifs
est ce que cela implique une fermeture
totale du site
la direction promet que le site a un
avenir qui ne fermera pas chez nokia sur
un site de 350 personnes il faut savoir
qu'à cent mille salariés chez nokia
aujourd'hui un site de r&d de 350
personnes il va rester sur les 350
peut-être 200 250 personnes en r&d s'est
passé pas viable surtout que les
justificatifs économique qu'on nous a
donnée hier c'est que le site était trop
petit donc ce n'est pas en diminuant
encore la taille du site qui va devenir
viable voilà donc les les activités qui
étaient hébergés sur lannion nous a dit
elle quitte lannion elles partent en
inde ou en pologne
parce que les le site est trop petit et
donc aider donc pas viable et on nous
dit le site deux fois plus petit va
rester viable donc c'est complètement
stupide mais bon c'est pas étonnant
c'est la stratégie globale de nokia
français on en a joué on les a utilisés
on a utilisé le crédit impôt recherche
on a utilisé
[Musique]
alcatel lucent les technologiques
d'alcatel lucent mais l'idée de nos cas
c'était pas du tout rester en france en
janvier 2019 la ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire avait exigé le maintien
de la recherche et du développement en
france selon vous comment lutter contre
ces restrictions à sion il avait promis
aucun licenciement contraint il y en a
il y en a eu quelques dizaines depuis
quelques années on voit la petite mais
là sur un site comme lannion où il y as
400 licenciements sur 770 salariés on
voit pas comment les gens vont pouvoir
partir et puis de toute façon on en est
plus là on en est venu à aucun
licenciement qu'on a on est au maintien
de la r&d en france on est durs
d'accompagnement social on est sûr qu
est ce que la france confère dans la 5g
dans les années qui viennent
roland tutrel secrétaire cfdt nokia
remercie d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci beaucoup iront du manifeste